说话人 1: 哈喽，兄弟们，欢迎来到真实社交，我是 Jackson 本人
说话人 1: 今天给大家带来一期比较特殊的案例，这个女生是后面把我给删掉了，我是去做了一个挽回的操作，把她重新给加了回来，后续的窗口也不错，反应也很好，是一个比较成功、比较经典的一个挽回的案例，大家可以参考一下
说话人 1: 我给大家介绍一下当时认识这个女生的一个背景
说话人 1: 当时是我出去撩妹，在一个酒吧的门口认识这个女生的
说话人 1: 她当时在等朋友，一个人在那里，我看到她背面很可以，我上去检查，她转过来，给我感觉非常的惊艳，是我很喜欢的很甜的一个长相，身材也非常的棒，一点
说话人 1: 都没有那种赘肉的感觉，还带有一点点的微微胖，她的身高也比我高啊，是172，给我感觉这个人非常的符合我的一个审美，我给她整体的分数可以给她打一个 7 分，她的性格就比较台妹的性格，也是一个长期属性，所以说我会给她分数要高一点，在7.5，对于我个人来讲，我给她打7.5，但是她外貌的分数
说话人 1: 只有 7 分
说话人 1: 我个人给女人打分数，外貌的分数最高只有 7 分，再往高了就是其他内涵，或者说她精神方面的一个东西，我才能给她加分了
说话人 1: 我废话不多说，兄弟们，咱们来看一个聊天记录
说话人 1: 这里当时是通过了，我给她打了一个招呼，我说有点唐突哈，我是杰杰，还是给了一个很常规的同理心，让她知道咱们是一个正常人
说话人 1: 她给我发了一个名字，一个表情
说话人 1: 她这个发的是她的外号，就她的小名，下面发的是她的真名，发了一个表情
说话人 1: 可以看出这个女生是比较有窗口的呀，所以说咱们要试探一下窗口是不是一个真实的窗口，去做一下升级，去做一下推拉，去做一下试探
说话人 1: 我说你成年了吗
说话人 1: 我不能撩未成年
说话人 1: 这里是在给一个价值啊，是给一个看法
说话人 1: 我的看法是，我觉得他没有成年，我又调侃了一下，还不能撩未
说话人 1: 未成年，就算是一个推拉吧
说话人 1: 她说我看起来像未成年吗
说话人 1: 发了一个惊恐的表情
说话人 1: 她这句话的意思是比较诧异，因为她的外表不是很小，但是她给我说话感觉她是很小的女生，所以说我会说她未成年，但她的外表一点都不小，她的外表反而来说还比较成熟，因为那个时候是比较冷嘛，她穿的是那种貂皮的，那种高筒的靴子，看起来确实是比较成熟的一个标准装扮
说话人 1: 我
说话人 1: 说女人的年龄我猜不准，这句话的意思是，赦免了我上一句话承担的一个后果
说话人 1: 就我上一句话，我是根据她谈吐推测出来她年龄不大
说话人 1: 这句话我说女人的年龄我猜不准，我估计她可能不知道我是根据什么推断出她的年龄，所以说我就懒得跟她掰扯了，我就直接发这句话
说话人 1: OK，我说感觉你像大学生，在这里也是做了一个冷读，就给她一种我是蛮有经验的感觉
说话人 1: 她
说话人 1: 说对，但是我成年了，哈哈
说话人 1: 我朋友都说我看起来很成熟，大家可以感受到女生是很有窗口的一个状态，因为可能那个时候晚上情绪比较高昂，刚好在外面玩
说话人 1: 她有窗口，有情绪，咱们就要马上立刻开始升级
说话人 1: 我直接进入两性的一个框架，我说我比你大很多，介意我这种叔叔吗
说话人 1: 我先给他说我的年龄比较大，经验可能比较多的一个意思，但我实际上我长得不像那种叔叔，所以说这是一个算是自嘲的一个感觉
说话人 1: 这个女生说，啊
说话人 1: 你看起来就 25 左右哎
说话人 1: 她这里就有一点好奇嘛，她说你看起来并没有那么大的一个意思，就勾起了女生的一个好奇心
说话人 1: 我经常会拿我的年龄来做一个反差的一个举例，不能说效果很好，但是它会带来一定的一个话题，可以让我进入一个男女框架，也可以让我去做一个筛选的一个操作
说话人 1: 我说我实话实说， 28 了
说话人 1: 你多少
说话人 1: 他说我21
说话人 1: OK，我大概知道她是大概是一个什么人群，什么范围的一个女生了，咱们要转换一下思路，怎么对付年龄的一个女生
说话人 1: 怎么撩年龄的一个女生
说话人 1: 我这里直接跟她邀约，我说下周哪天有空，打算接触一下，太晕了，准备回家了
说话人 1: 因为我当时在新兴地堡，玩，那里面可能抽烟的比较多，有点乌烟瘴气的，我的头就有点晕，我就准备回家休息了
说话人 1: 她说那
说话人 1: 那么快
说话人 1: OK，从这个点可以读出来，这个女生她是想见我们，至少潜意识她是这么想的，她不想我们走
说话人 1: 我说小学生男的太多了，我说那个酒吧全是男的，没有正妹，没有女生嘛
说话人 1: 咱们读出刚才那个信号，她说这么早就回家了，我就要给出我的一个窗口，我说你唱多晚
说话人 1: 很多兄弟在刚才那种情况，他是读不出那种窗口的，那个窗口是可以
说话人 1: 马上升级的，一定要注意那个东西
说话人 1: 我这里再做了一个申请，我说你唱多晚
说话人 1: 他说我 12 点去星星地堡，可能
说话人 1: OK，我听到这句话，我可能会放弃了，因为如果说等他到 12 点的话，还要等一个小时，太难熬了
说话人 1: 这里我先做了一个撤退，我说晚点再说了
说话人 1: 其实我更喜欢喝茶晒太阳，我的意思是，我应该会先撤了，如果我还在那里的话，晚点我再跟他联系
说话人 1: 同时突
说话人 1: 垫了下一次邀约要做什么事
说话人 1: 铺垫这个东西非常的重要，非常的精髓
说话人 1: 他说我也是，我不喜欢喝酒，但是我喜欢蹦迪，纯蹦
说话人 1: OK，这个女生她在自我复格，因为我喜欢喝茶晒太阳，她也开始对她自己复格，她说我也不喜欢喝酒
说话人 1: 她说她蹦迪是纯蹦，就没有跟什么男的聊骚啊，没有跟男的肢体接触啊，大概是形容她是这样的一个女生，是很好的一个信号
说话人 1: 如果说兄弟们，你们要把她的短期属性给察觉出来，还需要在后面做一些操作，给你们一个点，女人的默认属性
说话人 1: 都是长期属性，因为这个社会的评判机制非常非常他们的严重，就算是一个他们的超级大，她也不敢在街上他们的把衣服直接给脱掉，体无完肤的站在别人面前，不可能
说话人 1: 人，他都有最基本的一个社会评判框架，所以女人的默认属性是长期属性
说话人 1: 这里我给出了我的一个故事，我说我以前蹦迪穿保暖裤，蹦完出来衣服裤子全湿透
说话人 1: 这句话的意思是，因为我以前很怕冷嘛，我去蹦迪的时候都穿那种保暖裤，蹦完出来衣服裤子全湿透
说话人 1: OK，前半句是正常的一个很搞笑、很幽默的一个
说话人 1: 讲故事，后面的半句已经加入了性话题了，湿透
说话人 1: OK，这个女生她的经验可能比较多，因为她可能接触的男生比较多，她马上主动进入一个两性的框架，主动的察觉到这一条信息
说话人 1: 他说穿吊带，穿那么多干嘛
说话人 1: 氛围已经完全不一样了，兄弟们
说话人 1: 就不知不觉间，很圆滑、很丝滑的、很流畅的进入一个两性话题，而且是比较强烈的一个两性话题，不是那种很浅的
说话人 1: 我说特殊癖好是吧
说话人 1: 还叫我穿吊带
说话人 1: 这句话他有一个很深层的意思，在测试他的一个 SM 属性，同时还在测试一个抖 S 的属性，也是一个两性话题的一个节奏感
说话人 1: 他说穿个背心我爱看
说话人 1: 这里女生在提要求了，她说穿个背心我爱看，她可能喜欢
说话人 1: 有点肌肉，有点线条的一个男生，他在索取你的一个价值
说话人 1: OK，那我回了一句，我爱看女仆
说话人 1: 咱们要做一个价值交换，女生她在说想看背心
说话人 1: OK，那我们交换一下，公平一下，我爱看女仆
说话人 1: 我不是一个舔狗啊，你要什么我都会给你，我也有自己的要求的，你也要付出一些东西的
说话人 1: 这个东西在 PUA 文化里非常的经典，就是价值
说话人 1: 的一个交换
说话人 1: 比如说你跟女生去逛超市，女生要你帮她推购物车，OK，你可以给她推，但是你要把你的外套脱下来给她，让她帮你拿着，你才能给她推购物车
说话人 1: 如果说她什么都不愿意为你做，你就别帮她做，知道吧
说话人 1: 兄弟们，要价值交换
说话人 1: 然后她说不，你不爱，可是大街上穿，夏天穿背心很正常啊
说话人 1: 她这里再给她，她们的她
说话人 1: 把自己的索取合理化，女人就是天生的PUA，这句话完全没有毛病，她会自己被动的合理化她所有的一个东西，哪怕那个东西她是错的
说话人 1: 这里我没有理她这句话，我还是在做一个两性框架的一个加深，顺便再显示出我自己的一个有趣幽默的一个属性，就是这场对局不会很无聊
说话人 1: 我说羞羞，怕露出胸肌给人看见，不守妇道
说话人 1: OK，这里我给了我自己的一个价值点，因为我有练胸肌，让人看见了不守妇道，这是一个很反差的一个东西，她会瞬间觉得这个男生有点闷骚，又很有趣，她一瞬间都会有这样的感觉，那个吸引力一下就升高了
说话人 1: 她说给我看没关系，我不给别人说，完全进入了一个
说话人 1: 互相踢皮球的一个状
说话人 1: 状态非常的有性张力
说话人 1: 什么叫性张力
说话人 1: 兄弟们，这就叫性张力，给它拉到那个极点，它会很紧张，很兴奋，又感觉很危险，就是那种感觉
说话人 1: 拉开性张力，就像一根皮筋，你把它拉开，拉到很紧的时候那个感觉，那就叫张力
说话人 1: 我还是坚持我的一个框架，价值交换
说话人 1: 我说那我看黑丝总得交换一下，我甚至于把这个概念直接提出来
说话人 1: 总得交换一下，这样才公平，也很有逻辑，也能把妹子给干住，她也不会觉得在胡说八道
说话人 1: OK，第一个废测来了，兄弟们，废物测试来了，是一个非常好的一个信号，就代表女生的兴趣已经到了顶点，你一旦过了这个废物测试，吸引力马上到达另外一个层次
说话人 1: 废物测试，第一个废物测试是非常好的一个门槛，但是这个废物测试太他们的细微了
说话人 1: 很多人是察觉不到，她说不行，我怕我以后的男朋友会介意的
说话人 1: 很多兄弟如果换到你的角度，你可能觉得这个妹子她在拒绝你，她不想跟你什么什么
说话人 1: 其实这是她自己潜意识的一个自然反应
说话人 1: 女生的潜意识，她多年以来的一个经验会自动让她说出一些废物测试，来筛选你这个人
说话人 1: 如果你这个人抗压能力不够，你这个人心态不好，你这个人很屌丝，你前面就算装的再屌，废物测试一旦出现，你马上就会被一枪爆头
说话人 1: 所以你们看我这里是怎么化解的
说话人 1: 我说你扯犊子，差点我就信了
说话人 1: 我的意思是我在嘲笑她，在扯淡，你给我看一下黑丝，你以后的男朋友还会介意
说话人 1: 她在装，这个女生她在装，装成她自己是一个女神，很守妇道，很乖，很温柔，良家妇女的那种形象嘛
说话人 1: 就女生的社会评判
说话人 1: 会把他往那个方向推，但他到底是不是这样的人，还有待参考
说话人 1: 我这一句话就把他的面具给撕碎了，他说哈哈，他很尴尬的笑了，因为他心里知道，我知道他是什么样的人，他在装
说话人 1: 一瞬间，这一瞬间他会把你
说话人 1: 仔细听，兄弟，仔细体会我这句话，一瞬间，因为我这句话，他会一瞬间把你和其他人
说话人 1: 分隔开，其他人是一个标签，屌丝，你是一个标签，有趣的
说话人 1: 懂了没有
说话人 1: 兄弟们，仔细体会一下这种感觉，他会一瞬间给你分类，贴一个标签，他会以这个标签跟你相处的方式跟你相处
说话人 1: OK，我说我这辈子可能都没有女朋友三个字，其实我这里在暗示我接下来的一个短期属性啊
说话人 1: 他说努努力就有了，他
说话人 1: 还是想在测试你的框架，他还是把你往屌丝那方面做一个模拟，就看你能不能扛得住这种攻击
说话人 1: 我说，嗯，都是小情人，我直接把我的短期属性告诉她，以一个第三方的一个视角，我不是让她做我的小情人，我是在以一个第三方的视角形容我的一个经历，一个感觉，这样比较安全一点
说话人 1: 你如果说把她说成你的小情人，她可以直接拒绝你，所以这个
说话人 1: 很重要，她说啊，小情人是什么
说话人 1: 这个女的，他们的，我当时就发现这女的，她就喜欢装，因为她身边的那些舔狗太多了，兄弟们，不是可能，这个女生她身边的舔狗 100% 非常多，所以说她的面具会如此之厚，面具如此之厚，比我的脸皮还厚啊，比我的脸皮还要厚好几倍
说话人 1: 我这里再给她做更深一步的暗示，我说就是只有感情，我问她身体与精神，你更注重哪边
说话人 1: OK，这里我是准备再做一个深度的复格了，因为前面的吸引已经很高了，兄弟们
说话人 1: 一旦复格通过，女生就会喜欢上你，是真正的喜欢上你，知道吗
说话人 1: 你可以直接去牵她的手，直接去摸她的什么地方，一旦复格通过，这就是网聊要做到的一个点，复格通过，纯网聊啊，不用约会的那种，纯网
说话人 1: 泡妞，你一定要做到负责，你才有机会跟她发生关系
说话人 1: 她说没懂，出轨吗
说话人 1: 这里我不知道她是真的没懂，还是在装
说话人 1: 我要把我的想法给她阐述一遍，我才知道她真的一个信号
说话人 1: 我说我是比较喜欢精神多一点，不会很粘人，有分寸的那种
说话人 1: OK，这里我在说我不是一个很在乎颜值，更在乎的是内在内涵的一个东西，就比较高级的一些东西，比较深层的一些东
说话人 1: 然后我说，就所谓的知性，我觉得那种是精神的性感，很吸引我
说话人 1: 然后这个女生可能年龄比较小，她对这些东西她不是很理解，然后她的重心还是放在外表上面
说话人 1: 她问了身体指的啥，然后给我发了一个小孩的表情
说话人 1: 就她他们的还在装，所以说兄弟们，她身边舔狗越多的女生，她就越会PUA，那已经成了她的一个被动技能
说话人 1: 咱们这里直接拆穿她，你装
说话人 1: 我说不是，你是演的还是真的这么单纯
说话人 1: 我就直接给他明说了，就直接明说了
说话人 1: 我说就我理解的话，身体不只是性关系，陪伴也算
说话人 1: 身体不只是性关系，还有陪伴也算
说话人 1: 这句话的意思是，前面我是给的一个短期属性，后面我是给的一个长期属性，就身体层面
说话人 1: 就只要两个人是面对面那种，就算精神更多来说的话，是一种链接
说话人 1: 我说精神层面，更高级的一个层面，是一种链接，是一种频率，是一个频道
说话人 1: 当然我不知道她懂不懂我说的频道的意思，但是她大概能理解的到
说话人 1: 而且就算她不理解，我只是说出我的一个看法，我的一个价值观
说话人 1: 让他体会到我这个人，我是谁，大家理解一下这个点
说话人 1: 他说都要有，哈哈哈，OK，都要有，女生已经跟
说话人 1: 跟你聊骚，跟你聊性话题，已经聊到很深入的一个感觉了
说话人 1: 一旦一个女生能跟你聊到这么深入的一个感觉，她就是喜欢你的，OK
说话人 1: 懂了吗
说话人 1: 她就是喜欢你的，没有例外，只能说你能不能把这个喜欢维持住，能不能把这个吸引一直往上拉，拉到你跟她收尾，懂了吧
说话人 1: 只要你后续不犯错，你基本上是没啥问题的
说话人 1: 然后这里第一个兴趣指标来了，你
说话人 1: 是哪里人啊
说话人 1: 记得我说过什么吗
说话人 1: 只要女生问你是哪里人，对你这个人本身的一些信息感兴趣，她就已经对你这个人感兴趣了，已经喜欢你了，已经有很多信号的一个加持了
说话人 1: 所以说到这里不用怀疑，你把她当成女朋友聊就 OK 了
说话人 1: 我说会在重庆待到夏天，我也没说我具体是哪里人，我只会说我在重庆待到夏天，有长
说话人 1: 长期属性也有短期属性
说话人 1: OK，该确定的事已经确定了，我不想在微信上把你聊到高潮，我直接约你出来， 100% 成功率，这个时候就是 100% 成功率，这个时候邀约
说话人 1: 所以说你们邀约为什么邀约不出来
说话人 1: 因为你们前面做的太少了，做的太错了，知道吧
说话人 1: 所以你们要转换一下思路
说话人 1: 他说都可以啊，周一，女生都说都可以了
说话人 1: 你知道他的窗口有多大吗
说话人 1: 我说周内可以，我当天跟你确认
说话人 1: 到了当天，我说下午 3 点可以吗
说话人 1: 他说今天吗
说话人 1: 兄弟们还是那句话，你要有最基本的社交直觉，最基本的情商
说话人 1: 这句话的意思是，他说今天吗
说话人 1: 你不要说，哎，是今天，对，就是今天，怎么了
说话人 1: 很多时候他回复的消息，只要超出了你的意外，超出了你的大数据库，就说明他是在拒绝
说话人 1: 这里我会认为他是没有时间，我直接冷读他，我说昨晚你喝大了吗
说话人 1: 他说你说周内，哈哈，啥意思
说话人 1: 可能对这个时间的判断有错误
说话人 1: 这里我说今天你来得及吗
说话人 1: 不行明天啊，我说我以为你定的周一，因为他当时说了一个周一，他们的
说话人 1: 他说不是，你说周内，我以为就是周一不行
说话人 1: 这个女生她可能没上过班，她没有工作过，她认为周内
说话人 1: 你的意思就是周一不行，其他时间就是周内
说话人 1: 他说的是这个意思，搞了一个乌龙啊
说话人 1: 那没什么问题，咱们继续约就行了
说话人 1: 我说一看就没上过班，周内的意思是周一到周四，工作日嘛，周五、周六、周天是周末
说话人 1: 他说今天倒是可以，我们去哪呀
说话人 1: 我现在在外面买东西，我要回家收拾一下才行
说话人 1: 好吧，OK，窗口非常的大，吸引还是很高，因为他完全
说话人 1: 全没有一点拒绝的意思，直接就答应了
说话人 1: 这句话兄弟们记住，我现在在外面买东西，我要回家收拾一下才行
说话人 1: 什么意思
说话人 1: 女生她在投资，她要回家收拾一下
说话人 1: 女生出来她是要化妆、要收拾、要穿衣服、要挑好看的衣服穿、要喷很香的香水、要打扮自己的
说话人 1: 她可能现在素颜在外面买东西，也有可能随随便便，打扮很随便
说话人 1: 出去干什么
说话人 1: 他为了见我们，他需要回家投资一下，把自己打扮一下，收拾一下，以提高他在你面前的一个分数，非常好的一个信号，大家要察觉得到
说话人 1: 所以很明显我们的框架已经在他上面了
说话人 1: 我说就观音桥吧，你几点到
说话人 1: 她说她在干嘛，描述了她的一个状态，送了她朋友
说话人 1: 就女生具体跟你说她在做什么会耽误这次约会，你们就让她自己去做就好了，因为是很确定，很真实的一个回答
说话人 1: 不要这个时候又跳起来把框架拉得很硬，非要她什么什么，非要她去做什么，非要她要什么时候过来
说话人 1: 如果说你这样做，你的吸引瞬间会啪下降
说话人 1: 然后我刚才不是问了她几点到吗
说话人 1: 让她确定一下时间，然后她说她现在就是刚起床那种状态，可能比较不好看，可能比较邋遢，不是很适合见我的一个状态，她说她想回
说话人 1: 回家收拾一下
说话人 1: OK，这里咱们给出一个同理心，给出一个理由，给出一个理解的一个状态
说话人 1: 我说我知道你要收拾啊，但是你要给我一个时间，几点到，不然我不好安排时间
说话人 1: 我的意思是，我不是为了见你这一个女人而单独在那里疯狂的等你很久，在那里傻傻的等你很久
说话人 1: 咱们要给他传达出这样一个感觉，让他知道我们还是有选择的，框架还是比他高的
说话人 1: 随时随地面对女生都要有框
说话人 1: 也要有分寸
说话人 1: 他说好吧，我回去还要时间，我收拾了一个小时，差不多两个小时吧
说话人 1: 他说咱们晚上可以出去玩
说话人 1: 这句话他有两个意思，第一个意思是他可能想去酒吧玩，要喝酒之类的，但是我不喝酒，所以说我大概率不会陪他一起去
说话人 1: 第二个意思是晚上出去玩的意思是可能还能收尾的意思，大概先放在那里，看后续情况做一个操作
说话人 1: 你只需要知道你可以做什么操
说话人 1: 作，具体要做什么操作，得看当时的一个情况，得看当时女生的窗口
说话人 1: 我说再说吧，我晚点要工作，那就 5 点到，好吧
说话人 1: 他说我才打到车，这里我说不慌，好好化个妆
说话人 1: 我的意思是你不要急，你只需要 5 点到就行，因为那个时候还早嘛
说话人 1: 这里他出门的动力减弱了，他不是不想见我吗
说话人 1: 兄弟，他是出门确实比较麻烦，这个时候我们需要给予引导，给予鼓励，给予确信感，就是真的很想见他
说话人 1: 他说要不下次吧，我想睡觉
说话人 1: 我这里在嘲笑他纯K歌王，因为他当时站在是 KTV 外面的马路上面，那个 KTV 的名字叫纯K，所以说我当时想了这样一个东西，我就直接把这个东西抛出去
说话人 1: 在调侃，又是在有点不高兴，又给了一个幽默，他说屁，我说咱今天可用了半瓶发胶，OK
说话人 1: 这里我要给出我的一个诚意了，我的一个价值了
说话人 1: 我说我为了，当然我没有说为了见她用了半瓶发胶，我只是说咱们今天用了半瓶发胶，可能是为了她，可能是为了工作，因为我前面说了工作
说话人 1: 有这样的一个意思，让她觉得这个男生还是为我有投资，蛮有诚意的，可以见一下，我不去见她就有点对不起她
说话人 1: OK，她这里果然
说话人 1: 说真的吗
说话人 1: 那我有点不好意思不来了
说话人 1: 她说我才到家
说话人 1: 这里我又给出一个价值，一个调侃，我说作为精神小妹，得拿出精神
说话人 1: 她说我哪里像精神小妹了
说话人 1: 女人她永远会把你说的话归到她自己身上
说话人 1: 其实我就是在开玩笑，在调侃
说话人 1: 她说我哪里像精神小妹了
说话人 1: 她很在乎我看她的一个看法，这相当于是一个推了
说话人 1: 我说那倒没有，是我爱押韵
说话人 1: OK，这
说话人 1: 里我拉回来了一个操作，一个小推拉，把他的情绪给稍微的做一个起伏
说话人 1: 到了那个点，我又拍了拍他，就看他出门没有
说话人 1: 他给我发了一个表情，他问你在干嘛
说话人 1: OK，大概这个时候我还没感觉到他有出来，我在这里做了一个调度，做了一个跟进的一个操作，给他发了位置
说话人 1: 他说不知道，他问哪里，我说观桥啊，你到哪里了
说话人 1: 他说，哦，我以为就是他们的，他说我以为不来了，行吧，我来了
说话人 1: 就这里，他不是一个生气的口气，他是他们的非常嗲，非常台妹，非常黏的一个口气，非常黏的一个语音，他在学我说他们的
说话人 2: 哦，我以为就是他们的，我以为不来了呢，行吧，我来了
说话人 1: 就像
说话人 1: 就他
说话人 1: 他真的像男女朋友之间的一个怎么说呢
说话人 1: 那种感觉，只有你们自己去体会了才知道
说话人 1: 我还是做了一个跟进，我说我妈说感情的事必须趁热打铁，发一个表情
说话人 1: 这里我们还是在做一个调度的事情，他说我到哪里，观音桥哪里，我给他发了位置，整个是一个调度的事情
说话人 1: OK，这里也见到他了，我们去星巴克喝一个咖啡
说话人 1: 约完会之后也是很正常的一个流程，就是
说话人 1: 牵手，拥抱，挽手
说话人 1: 在约会途中，我给了非常多的一个短期属性，吸引他们的非常的强，但是我不想跟她发展一个长期关系，所以说我短期的框架非常的硬，硬到什么程度
说话人 1: 硬到这个女生她问我，大概是什么样的一个情况
说话人 1: 我说是一个搭讪教练，是一个情感博主，我每天都会去认识妹子
说话人 1: 我把这些事情都告诉她了，她都还想跟我发
说话人 1: 发展长期关系
说话人 1: 我给你们举个例子，他问了一个问题给我，他说如果说你有女朋友了，还会去吗
说话人 1: 还会去认识女生吗
说话人 1: 我犹豫了两秒，还是想着不要欺骗这个女生，我说我会
说话人 1: 就框架硬到这种地步，兄弟们，一个7.5分的妹子摆在你的面前，你只要答应了跟她长期关系，你们他们的就能干上一炮，甚至于你每天可以干
说话人 1: 但是我忍住了，框架是我的一切，我不能欺骗这个女生，我不能为了睡她，为了干她，我去做一些欺骗，做一些虚假承诺
说话人 1: 我是有底线的人，但是我还是很喜欢她，因为她确实让我很上头
说话人 1: 你知道她看起来很吸引人，是那种有短期属性，但是她本人又是非常长期属性
说话人 1: 就当时是让我非常上头的一个女生，所以说我也会
说话人 1: 去做一个挽回的一个操作，这里是约完会过后，当时我送她上地铁的时候
说话人 1: 后，我是去做了一个接吻的一个操作，但是他有点抗拒，因为可能觉得我太浪了，价值不太匹配
说话人 1: 这里我送他走了之后，他说气死我了
说话人 1: 我说哪怕不是你的理想型，我也不想骗你
说话人 1: 就我给他表达了我的一个真实想法
说话人 1: 他说不是，我说的是你亲我干嘛
说话人 1: 我说他们的，我是个男人啊
说话人 1: 他说哈哈哈
说话人 1: 我表达的意思是我是个男人啊，我看到我喜欢的人，我也会想去做一
说话人 1: 些事情啊，这不是很正常吗
说话人 1: 我说你的脸那么好看，他们的
说话人 1: 她发了哦哦哦
说话人 1: 我说第一次接吻都被你破坏了
说话人 1: 她说这种事情要征求我的意见啊
说话人 1: 这个时候她还在给她们的废物测试啊，她妈接吻这种东西能问吗
说话人 1: 女人说话她是不动脑子的，她只会为了情绪考虑
说话人 1: 兄弟们不要听这句话，你不能问一个女生，我可以跟你接吻吗
说话人 1: 一旦你问一个女生
说话人 1: 我可以跟你接吻吗
说话人 1: 你得到的答案永远是No，永远是No，记住，永远是不可能
说话人 1: 接吻这个东西只能他们的责任扛在你自己身上，你不能让女生扛责任，知道吧
说话人 1: 我说作为男人得扛起责任啊，所以我当那个坏蛋
说话人 1: 她这里后面就没回我了， ASD 反机制已经启动了她的，因为她无法给这段关系合理化，因为咱们当时做的一个操作太激进了，所以需要把舒适感，所以
说话人 1: 后面需要补充一下舒适感
说话人 1: 这里隔了几天，我再给他打了一个招呼，发了一个表情
说话人 1: 他没有回我，又隔了三天，我又给他发了一个消息，这个时候他就把我删了
说话人 1: OK，到了这个点，我在想用什么办法把他给挽回
说话人 1: 我当时是给他发了一个验证消息，我说 Jackson 申请满血再战，就申请满血复活，也是给出一个幽默感，还有一个诚
说话人 1: 然后她给我回复了一句，她说太可怕了，哪有第一次见面就接吻的
说话人 1: 她没有通过，她在验证消息上给我回复了一句话
说话人 1: 这个时候咱们就要给出你的长期属性，你的舒适感，一定要在这个时候给，不给你就死定了
说话人 1: 我回了一句，我说或许能让你看到 Jackson 的另外的一面，像小猫的一面，就给
说话人 1: 给了他一个长期属性
说话人 1: OK，你喜欢那种长期的一个关系，你可以看我的另一面，再做决定
说话人 1: 舒适感已经给到他了，他又回复我，他说太吓人了，你就是个
说话人 1: 这里他已经把情绪给释放掉了，他说我是个
说话人 1: 我回了一句，很经典，很的一个惯例，也是一个很幽默的话术，来化解紧张的氛围，一个很危险的氛围
说话人 1: 他不是说我吗
说话人 1: 我就回了他，我是蛇皮，但是我不老，谢谢赶紧通过一下，在这个验证消息上面聊的很，我就发了这样的话给他
说话人 1: 他不是说吗
说话人 1: 这里通过了之后，他说老，因为我说我不老嘛，我是蛇皮我不老
说话人 1: 他在跟我杠，他说老
说话人 1: 给我发了个表情，这里我说他们的差点失恋了，因为我当时有点上头，我又想给一点舒适感，所以说我
说话人 1: 我会发这样一句话，到了晚上，我是在新兴地堡玩，我给她发了一个视频，就代表我在这里玩
说话人 1: 我说堡子都没几个正妹，我的意思是我在新兴地堡，就是想去找正妹
说话人 1: 她说我也在，你们有没有座位
说话人 1: 我带了两个，可是没人敢和我们拼
说话人 1: 我当时是去霓虹了，我说我在霓虹了，她说好吧，无语，好累啊
说话人 1: 后面就是我跟她一起在霓虹玩的一个后续了，给大家总结一下
说话人 1: 这是一个比较经典的一个挽回案例，里面有非常多的一些正常情况，我不建议大家去做一个挽回的操作，因为我跟你的角度是不一样的，我就算挽回不了，我也可以继续去转盘子，继续去认识正妹，我也不会遭受到很强的一个伤害
说话人 1: 但是你们如果是去做挽回，就说明这个女人对你们来说很重要，那个后果是你们承担不了的，所以说我不建议去做一个挽回的一个操作，尽量的去转盘子，大家仔细体会一下我讲的一个技术点，可以给你们的聊天带来很好的一个
说话人 1: 提升
说话人 1: OK，这里是真实社交，我是杰森，下期再见